[Musique]
sur la côte est de l'inde la ville de
pourri et ses 250 mille habitants
connaissent une petite révolution elle
est la première du pays à bénéficier
d'une eau du robinet est potable et de
qualité en plus des milliers de
connexions domestique 400 robinets ont
été installés dans différents quartiers
aujourd'hui literie d'un programme
ambitieux
ce robin air vraiment tout le monde même
les pauvres maintenant c'est facile de
trouver de l'eau potable 24 heures sur
de l'eau potable 24 heures sur 24
parties jusque dans les campagnes
indiennes d'ici 2024 une promesse faite
par le premier ministre marraine la mode
il ya près de trois ans en périphérie de
la ville de pourri basse en ti a
désormais accès à l'eau potable juste
devant chez elle
elle vit dans cette maison de fortune et
ce nouveau point doit changer sa vie
mais la mare à l'acier la maison et là
c'est le robinet d'eau avant devaient
aller loin pour trouver de l'eau mais
maintenant c'est facile pour les enfants
de bassan petit cet accès facile à l'eau
potable aura un impact sur leur santé
mais aussi leur avenir
avant de puiser de l'eau dans les mares
et des lacs
c'était une eau sale qui nous rendait
souvent malades avec les enfants et puis
c'était loin on devait emmener les
petits avec nous car on ne pouvait pas
les laisser tout seul
du coup il n'avait pas assez de temps
pour faire leurs devoirs
pour tenir ses promesses le gouvernement
indien a prévu d'investir plus de 45
milliards d'euros sur cinq ans
et sur cette carte vous pouvez voir d'où
on est parti en 2019
moins de 2% des foyers indiens avaient
un robinet d'eau potable chez eux
aujourd'hui tout le monde a une
connexion dans 6 états du pays
évidemment c'est un gros défi car nous
parlons de 600 mille villages et de plus
de 160 millions de foyers à relier dans
tout le pays
c'est un vrai challenge et d'ingéniérie
car il faut trouver de l'eau et des
sources fiables
parfois loin du village
il y à des régions arides des régions
difficiles d'accès ou avec une eau de
mauvaise qualité
selon des chiffres officiels
47% des foyers ruraux disposerait
désormais d'un accès à l'eau potable
pour la moitié restante du pays l'accès
à une eau buvable s'avère toujours
compliqué et achetés quotidiennement de
l'eau en bouteille représente un coût
nul pour le budget de la majorité des
foyers dans ce village à une centaine de
kilomètres de pourri les nouveaux
raccordements semblent pourtant prêts
mélo n à sortir de terre
ça fait un an qu'ils ont creusé les
canalisations il y a 6 mois des
ingénieurs mis en place la moitié des
tuyaux pour l'instant on doit toujours
aller loin et ramené de 3 à bout de bras
ça fait mal et à cause de ce problème de
qualité d'eau on doit parfois marcher
encore plus loin
comme partout en inde ce sont souvent
les femmes qui se charge d'aller
chercher l'eau pour leur famille parfois
plusieurs fois par jour avant la nuit
manika jalil ans le mouvement
dans ce village 700 personnes se
partagent un seul point d'eau utilisable
pour leurs besoins quotidiens
boire cuisiner faire la vaisselle et se
laver
5 km aller retour c'est la distance que
malika et ses voisines doivent parcourir
pour procurer de l'eau à leur famille
une eau vital mais aussi un poison pour
ceux qui la consomment chaque année en
inde une centaine de milliers d'enfants
de moins de cinq ans meurent de diarrhée
causés par l'eau qu'ils boivent
en buvant cette eau on perd l'appétit
surtout les enfants et parfois après
manger ils ont des reflux et vomissent
leur nourriture
tous les ans 40 millions d'indiens
développent des maladies liées à l'eau
potable
quand on cuit notre riz dans cette eau
il devient jaune mais on n'a pas le
choix
en attendant que le gouvernement nous
relie au réseau d'eau potable tout ce
qu'on peut faire c'est bouillir cette
eau
[Musique]
selon l'unicef plus de la moitié des
femmes en inde rural passe en moyenne 35
minutes par jour à chercher de l'eau
l'équivalent de 25 jours de travail par
an pour chacune d'entre elles avec les
frais médicaux engendrés par les
contaminations le manque d'accès à une
eau potable coup ton corps à l'inde plus
d'un demi milliard d'euros chaque année
[Musique]